hi this is presto occur the
mathematician John Conway devised a
clever method to calculate the day of
the week from a date known as the
Doomsday rule in this video I'll teach
you how to apply the method for dates in
2016 and then I'll extend the method for
any date up to 2099 to get started
2016 is a leap year in any leap year the
following dates always fall on the same
day of the week while this list may look
intimidating it's only twelve dates to
remember and there are patterns within
the dates which will make them easy to
remember for example look at the dates
four four six six eight eight ten ten
and twelve twelve in even months that
are for higher the value to remember are
the double days where the day value
equals the month value for the last line
of dates you can think about the phrase
I work from 9:00 to 5:00 at 7-eleven
this will give you the dates 9 5 7 11
and you can swap the numbers to get 5 9
and 11 7 the date in March I think about
is pi day because the constant pi is
approximately 3.14 to 29 is the last day
of February and you can think about 1 4
because a leap year happens every four
years now in 2016
January 4th falls on a Monday which
means all of these dates fall on a
Monday this will give you an anchor
point within each of the 12 months which
will allow you to compute any other date
within the year for example what day of
the week will Christmas 1225 fall on we
look for our closest reference point
which will be 1212 and we know this
falls on a Monday that means one week
later will be a Monday and two weeks
later will also be a Monday so one day
before that will be a Sunday so 1225
must fall on a Sunday
you can speed up the mental calculation
by subtracting the two values of the
date when you have 1225 you think about
the closest date as being 12:12 now we
can compute the number of days between
1212 and 1225 by subtracting the day
values of 25 minus 12 equals 13 we then
know that every seven days will be the
same day of the week so we reduce modulo
7 to get an offset of negative 1 so we
need one day before which is a Sunday so
that means this is another way we figure
out Christmas is on a Sunday let's do
another example when which day of the
week will July 4th be on our closest
reference point will be 7 11 which is a
Monday now July 4th is one week before
that
so our offset will be zero and that
means July 4th will also be on a Monday
now if you want to extend this method
for any other year there's one slight
modification you want to make the dates
to 29 and 1/4 apply only for leap years
so when you can't want to calculate
using this method in other years a
common year which is not a leap year
it's going to be one day before the days
we've given in February in January so
the last day in February in elite beer
is 229 but in a common year it's 228 and
for January 4th we remember that for
leap years happening every four years in
a common year which is the other three
years it happens on 1/3 so you can apply
the Domesday method by remembering these
dates for common years and leap years
they'll always fall on the same day of
the week now in order to apply this
method you need to know when January 3rd
or January 4th falls on so there's a
formula for that what I like to do is I
like to think about the day of the week
that New Year's falls on and then I make
the adjustment for January 3rd or
January 4th so to get this calculation
started we start out by putting the days
of the week in numerical coats starting
with Sunday being 0 and
Saturday being six you can remember
these using mnemonics zero being Sunday
you can think about his nuns day one is
Monday or Wednesday two is Tuesday or
two a day three is Wednesday or trebles
day threes a day four is Thursday or
fours day five is Friday five day and
six a Saturday or six a day now here's
the formula for calculating the day code
for a year if you have a year 2000 YY
the day code will equal negative one
plus the year plus the year divided by
four rounded up and you take that whole
result and make it modulo 7 so let's try
and figure out when will January first
two thousand fifty five which day of the
week that'll land on our year is fifty
five so we calculated the day code by
substituting in fifty five so we get
negative one plus 55 plus fifty five
over four and we want to round that up
modulo 7 55 over four is thirteen point
seven five which we round up to be 14 we
then end up with sixty-eight mod seven
the closest multiple of seven will be 63
so 68 is five more than 63 so we figured
out the day code is five which means
January 1 2000 55 will land on five day
which is Friday so now we can figure out
any date in 2055 like when is December
twenty-fifth 2055 we know that January
1st is on a Friday so we calculate two
days later January 3rd will be a Sunday
now we know all of the dates we've
memorized will land on a Sunday so that
means twelve twelve will land on a
Sunday and two weeks later 12 26 will
also be a Sunday therefore 12 25 will
land on a Saturday so the Doomsday
method is a very cool way that you can
mentally calculate any date and you'll
be very surprised how often this comes
in handy and other people will be
surprised how quickly you'll be able to
know the day of the week just from the
day
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel and make videos
on math and game theory you can catch me
on my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at pressure Locker and you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description